I am Christopher haggis back vice
president of research and development
for protein and cell analysis at thermo
fisher scientific i'm excited to welcome
you to our virtual event exploring the
cell advances in cell analysis and
protein workflows during this event you
will be able to access live webcast from
our R&D scientists covering a broad
range of topics including flow cytometry
cell imaging western analysis and
protein quantitation you will get tips
and tricks for fluorescence microscopy
guidelines for using multiplex
immunoassays the basics of flow
cytometry and more in addition you can
explore our virtual labs find out about
all of our latest products in the
exhibit hall and browse our educational
content in the learning center after the
life event we welcome you to come back
often to access all of our educational
content including scientific posters
how-to videos and on-demand webinars
that cover protein analysis and
detection as well as cell analysis
related techniques and applications
thank you and I hope that you enjoy the
event